before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
well
before we
tag in the next era
how about an overview
[Music]
so yes it's true gypnol's era is over
but now that it is finally done
I think it's worth taking a look back
and trying to
sort my feelings on it overall because
it's been a heck of a ride we had series
11 which I very much wanted to like
structurally was doing a lot of things I
wanted it was focusing on more
self-contained stories it wasn't doing a
big Mystery Box thing it wasn't loading
it with a ton of
um you know old villains it wasn't
banking as much on Nostalgia was trying
to be a newer thing
it also didn't work especially well for
me for a lot of the episodes series 12 I
mostly liked quite a bit better as it
then proceeded to bring in a whole bunch
of stuff that is old and nostalgic and
reintroduced a mystery box with the
Timeless child which
you know mystery boxes I should do a
dedicated video on my thoughts on those
in Doctor Who specifically at one point
but
you know we move forward until we
actually got to what the Timeless child
was and
I hated that idea I hated that concept
and then we got to flux which seemed
deeply compromised by covet at best and
did not really properly follow up on
what had been done in series 12. then we
had the closing specials Eve of the
Daleks I liked that one but then we had
legend of the sea Devils which I enjoyed
well enough but it's the epitome of
disposable I never need to see it again
and I was surprised how much I like
power of the doctor but again
it didn't actually seem to deal with a
lot of what came before
there's a whole bunch of stuff that for
me to just examine and look at
feels like it was brought up possibly
even set up to do more stuff with later
and then it just
didn't
now I had my initial interpretation as
to why this was
but now I have my different
interpretation of why this was
so my initial interpretation of why this
was based off just looking at the works
themselves because looking at series 11
series 12 the very severe changes from
no multi-parters barely anything even
close to an overarch or story
self-contained stuff no old characters
to a whole bunch of old stuff a mystery
box and massively shaking up canon in a
way that only has meaning if you are an
older fan and most of them didn't like
it to this supposedly completely
serialized story that also kind of
wasn't and felt like it was trying to do
10 things in a space built for maybe
five something that disjointed to me my
normal interpretation of that would be
this is something that if it ever knew
what it wanted to be it kept changing
and didn't have the confidence in itself
if I didn't know better and that isn't
if because as I do now know better and
we'll get to that but if I didn't know
better my interpretation of this
regardless of how much you'd like any or
all of these series they shift and
change the way this gets approached so
fundamentally every single series under
China's run
the read I would have had is maybe there
was a plan initially but it kept getting
changed because of other stuff now in
the case of flux we know there were some
changes that happened flatly because of
covet that affected the way it could be
shot it affected how many episodes they
could shoot but in the case of say the
transition from series 11 to series 12
that felt very much like oh we tried
something but the response wasn't quite
what we liked let's now do all the stuff
that we didn't do last time it felt
reactive it felt a response to the
reception chipnall himself at least
claims that's not the case now if you
just want to flatly not believe him
I suppose you can do that
given that he doesn't have the job
anymore
I'm not sure what incentive he would
have to lie while he was still
potentially going to do more series
there would theoretically be some
incentive for him to paint his feelings
about his work so far in the best light
possible because he doesn't want to
buckle confidence in his ability to do
things and if he's kind of like oh
people didn't like what we did uh we're
I'm sorry we'll do better that just
seems like an artist with no
self-confidence whatsoever and I don't
think he would do that
but now while I say now back in April is
specifically where I'm pulling as a main
source from this he gave an interview
with Doctor Who magazine now remember in
April
all the stuff involving him was shot it
was done some of it wouldn't air until a
while later but he was done at that
point it was all over for him so again
he had no incentive to lie or to
sugarcoat things and even admitted to a
few failings now unfortunately
I'm getting pretty much all this second
hand because Doctor Who magazine
um you have to pay to get it and I'm
frankly in a little bit of a financial
crunch right now there's my patreon I'll
plug that early if you want
any help uh is good but you know I I
don't have the money to just throw at it
just to double check what I was seeing
elsewhere now I did go to multiple
sources in terms of places and blogs and
YouTubers Etc who synopsized what he
said and some even pulled what appeared
to be direct quotes and it was
consistent enough that I don't think any
of these people were twisting his words
they were just presenting As Much from
the interview as they could that
wouldn't amount to copyright uh
infringement by just flat out reposting
the thing So based off that interview my
interpretation
of chiminal just running around like a
chicken with his head cut off and not
knowing what he wanted or maybe
initially knowing what he wanted but
then panicking at the response and
trying to do something else and going
for a completely different feel and then
not even really sticking with that
because he doesn't pick up the plot
points of things like The Fugitive
doctor like the Timeless child in
anything more than tiny conciliatory
ways and then gives us a finale that
doesn't really touch back on hardly any
of this stuff other than to just kind of
acknowledge that okay yes that existed
it feels
undisciplined it feels like somebody
should be going yeah I really didn't
have a handle on this it kind of went
out of my control
what shipnell said in that article and
like some as I said some YouTubers
already reported on this way back when
it came out but now I want to talk about
it in the context of his error actually
being over
he expressed
not a lot of regret he said he felt he
was leaving the position of showrunner
with no unfinished business
which was the main thing that I would
assume he had because again the Timeless
child feels like it didn't go anywhere
like we had this massive reveal that is
a complete and uttered shake-up of so
much of what we know about the doctor's
history about the doctor as a person
about Gallifreyan history in general
which we don't even know that much about
really unless you like dive into
literally every aspect of Doctor Who
media for some presented in the show we
don't know that much but it upends a lot
of it
and it doesn't really massively impact
anything after that like there's a
little bit tiny bit of an identity
crisis thing
at the end of that episode of the
Timeless children and a little bit of
that lingers in The Following episode
which was Revolution of the Daleks but
in flux like we see an appearance of Joe
Martin's doctor but no real additional
context we get an acknowledgment of tech
taeyoon who factored into the Timeless
child editions but gets killed and
doesn't really impact the immediate
story it just felt like lore dumps that
I had always assumed
were meant to be in service of something
I'd always assumed that this was set up
for a story that he wanted to tell and
needed to make these changes to tell it
but at this point it really does seem
like he did it for its own sake
and
some of the things he said that really
leads me to that conclusion include
things like admitting he doesn't know
where the doctor comes from
this whole thing that he plants that the
doctor is not actually from Gallifrey
but is from somewhere else he doesn't
know where
and that he has a opinion of where he
thinks Joe Martin's fugitive Dr Falls
and the doctor's life in in the doctor's
timeline but doesn't say what that is
basically intentionally leaving it up to
interpretation
the idea
that that's the goal
to just have this stuff there
but not to do anything with it
to introduce these very disruptive
Concepts and The Fugitive doctor I was
fairly prepared to roll with
these are very big disruptive contexts
you're in you're introducing very
different toys into the toy chest and
they just sit there
and maybe another Creator will pick them
up maybe they won't and general himself
even acknowledged yeah somebody might
undo this
okay but then if somebody does
what was the point
because here's the thing with retcons
and how they work yes nearly anything
you write and a long-running thing
whether it be Doctor Who or comic books
or whatever has the potential to be
undone the particular impact that you
did to a character or their history or
whatever whatever status quo change you
make can be undone and rolled back
but there's still something left when
that happens we still have whatever
stories came about and could only have
come about during the time when what you
did was Canon and was not retconned so
even if it is retconned in a way that
the meaning changes we still have those
stories
what stories did you tell
with these changes
and so if and when somebody decides to
reverse it which I've said before I
actually don't think anyone should
bother I think you should be treated the
same way that Doctor Who treated the I'm
half human on my mother's side thing
from the Palm again TV movie which is
ignore it move on forget it happened but
if somebody does
then this truly becomes pointless
because we don't even still have the
stories that came out of it it's really
mind-boggling to me
the way that he approached
his work on Doctor Who and I don't even
think all of it was bad I don't even
think all of his scripts in specific are
bad
but
this is some JJ Abrams nonsense
this idea of ooh it's big it's
disruptive it's mysterious what does it
mean
I don't understand the headspace of any
creative person who's going to approach
work that way there are clearly some who
do even some successful people but like
I I don't I don't understand
I don't think I can ever understand
because again
there is this and I've seen it be said
in my comments and like even before
chipmunk effectively confirmed it in
this interview
people said well you know part of the
reason for the Timeless child was to
bring the mystery back to the doctor
okay on the one hand I get that that is
an aspect of the doctor that has kind of
been lost over time because when Doctor
Who was first introduced we had no idea
who this person was we didn't find out
that there were really even others of
his species until several years into the
show we didn't get a name for time Lords
for several years after that we didn't
get a name for Gallifrey for years after
that like what little information we
have has been drip fed over a long time
and as that happens as Gallifreyan time
Lords became demystified which isn't the
thing I think is good but it's kind of
the natural thing that's going to happen
when something runs this long and I
actually think wow I kind of wish there
was less demystification of Gallifrey
than there has been to try and undo that
by suggesting that the doctor isn't even
from there
but having no intention to do anything
more with that the thing is
the loss of mystery of a character while
regrettable and something that like
you'll miss you'll miss over time that's
also the kind of thing you can't bring
back
without
traumatic consequences because
mystery is the natural outcropping of
not knowing much and it's really hard to
tell an interesting story over what's
coming up on 60 years without ever
revealing more about that character the
mystery is going to fade
because there is story potential in
giving some more information people who
hang around for as long as Doctor Who
fans have do want to know some things
not all of us want to know everything I
don't but people want to know some
things
the thing is you can't just roll us back
to 1963 where we have no idea who the
doctor is
because that's not the normal now
that is what the normal was 60 years ago
that nobody knew who the doctor was but
people's normal now and for decades has
been we don't know everything about the
doctor's life we still don't know who
the heck Susan's parents were we don't
know if y'all assuming Susan is actually
the doctor's granddaughter we don't know
if the doctor had a son a daughter both
multiple children who with we don't know
any there's tons of stuff we do not know
but we're used to knowing a certain
amount
and suddenly going oh no you don't know
anything you don't get to just leave it
like that because the new normal and I'm
not talking about like narrative status
quo I'm talking the normal
relationship between the audience and
the doctor for decades has been we know
somewhat more or less what your deal is
with still some huge sizable gaps
but we more or less kind of know your
general deal
that's what people
have as their relationship
and while some people
probably do like having the mystery
reignited like oh now we don't know oh
it's all mysterious again like
that had no appeal to me my core issue
with the Timeless child thing if you
don't remember was the fact that it made
the doctor too important cosmically
speaking because now the time Lords only
know how to regenerate because of the
doctor and I've railed before about how
I don't like the doctor to be that
important
I like the doctor to be incredibly
important to the people who encounter
the doctor the people who the doctor
saves not on a universal scale it was
part of my issue with Moffat Sarah as
well to be completely honest so just to
reiterate where my big issue with that
whole thing came in but while some
people may go oh it's mysterious again
you can't be surprised that a very large
chunk if not a majority of the audience
goes
I don't know how to relate to this
anymore you you now presented a huge
hole are you going to fill it in with
anything and then are either angry or
confused when you go no I like the whole
and look as I said I'm not somebody who
needs answers to everything
I've got massive amounts of material in
my own dang novel tons of stuff that I
know about the world the characters in
the setting that's not in the book
because it didn't impact the story so
like in terms of not laying out
everything start to finish and not
giving answers to everything I get that
lots of stuff gets overexplained but
there's a difference between over
explaining and literally no explanation
whatsoever if you're going to try and
get away with not explaining it
what I do feel you have an obligation to
do is to make it clear why it doesn't
matter
if you want an example of this I would
point to something like Inception from
Christopher Nolan there was all this
needless discourse about whether or not
the top that's spinning at the end Falls
over or not to indicate whether or not
he's still in a dream or if he's in the
real world and the thing that all of the
people making their hot takes and their
interpretations and their analysis and
their endings explained videos about
that failed to pick up and it's in the
text of the movie if you're paying
attention
the movie makes it clear we don't see
whether or not it falls over because it
doesn't matter if he's in the real world
or not what matters is he walked away
from the top he has decided that this is
his reality so it doesn't matter if it's
the real world or not or if it's still a
Dream It's the reality he's chosen so
that's why we don't see whether or not
the top falls over because that's not
the point the point is he chose to leave
it behind because this is what he's
choosing to be his reality
so if you're going to present us with a
lack of answers at the very least
present us properly thematically with
the reason why it doesn't actually have
to be there why we don't actually need
the answers and general tried
tried to do this
but it it is the weakest possible way to
do it because in the Timeless child
there's the whole interaction with Joe
Martin in The Matrix that basically
amounts to Joe Martin saying have you
ever limited by who you were before
and the answer is no and I agree
but if it doesn't change who she is
why is it here
because effectively in that story she's
just taken out of it stuck into a
Exposition machine and she gets all this
stuff dumped on her she's not
participating in the story and then
determines oh well this doesn't matter
anyway
that's not telling us that it we don't
need an answer because this is the real
Point that's literally telling us
the thing you just spend a bunch of time
with doesn't
matter
I can almost kind of if I squint sort of
see
what ship no might have been trying to
do
but the fact that he is
expressing as much satisfaction with his
work as he did in that interview
is confounding to me and like I want to
be clear it's not like he didn't own up
to any problems he was very upfront
about the fact that he thinks the Battle
of ranskorov Callos is by far the worst
script that he ever wrote and it's
literally a first draft because he had
to go back and help with rewrites and
revisions on everybody else's script as
kind of a consequence of the fact that a
lot of the writers he brought in didn't
have a background in sci-fi so he had to
help adjust their scripts to make it
actually fully work for Doctor Who but
that meant he did not have time to
properly revise that finale and he's
very upfront about that so I don't want
to make it seem like he's doing nothing
but going no I'm happy no I'm great no
it's uh no it's awesome he's not he's
acknowledging faults but he doesn't seem
to think any of this is anything other
than exactly what he wanted to do which
I mean if the man got to do the stories
he wanted for the most part
I can be happy for him in the abstract
it's nice when artists get to do what
they wanted to do
I guess I just don't understand
why this was what he wanted to do
and I also want to want to emphasize the
fact that even my initial interpretation
that at this point I don't stand by
anymore that shibnol was scrambling kind
of responding to maybe not either not
being happy with earlier series or
responding to criticism like that's not
automatically a Bad Thing nor would he
be the only one to do it I think you can
see that Moffett was kind of doing that
as time went on when the doctor uh
Capaldi's doctor especially was viewed
as maybe a bit too harsh and abrasive he
got silly and goofy and you know forced
cool in series nine with him isn't that
like this oh you really are new aren't
you and he flipped from one series being
pretty much all self-contained to one
series being mostly two-parters
but that felt less like
um a direct response to criticism of the
show and more of him trying to keep
himself invigorated with the project and
sort of imposing new things like oh what
if we did it this way that felt and I
mean it's a feeling that felt more like
chasing creative energy than being a
reaction but some certain aspects of it
I'm sure were direct reactions to how
people felt about things they did or
didn't like about his work up to that
point his his stretch for Matt Smith
through Peter Capaldi does feel like at
various points it is reacting to if not
directly responding to stuff that was
going on in terms of the response to his
work how much it was I'm sure he would
argue very little but I still feel like
it's there at least a little bit so I
don't want to completely bash that as a
concept and sometimes you need the
feedback to realize that what you
thought was working isn't even Landing
with your intended audience because like
look any any Creator can make something
that is what they want and maybe doesn't
land with the audience but if part of
your goal was to create something
crowd-pleasing then yeah maybe the
feedback matters
chibnol and Moffett before him seem to
at least claim that they largely tried
to not take in the criticism in the
online discourse which for their own
mental health was would have been the
right thing to do absolutely no question
about that so I'm not even going to say
they should have waited into all that
um especially chimnal because holy crap
to quote James Stephanie Sterling the
fan base
exhausting I get that but it's I just
keep coming back to
if the way that you approach this wasn't
in some way a response or reaction to
how people felt about your work
I just
don't understand because it really does
feel like the Timeless child was set up
at the very end of series 12. touched on
a little bit I think a lot of us
expected it to factor a fair bit in flux
in them when it didn't we assume well
it's it's gonna have to come up in the
specials right because it it hasn't led
to hardly anything
and
to have that
be all he planned
that all he ever planned to do to follow
up was a little bit of a tiny sliver of
an existential crisis briefly for the
doctor reintroduced Tech taeyoon who
does almost nothing kill her have the
watch plant it plant it very much as a
ooh we could bring this back later and
then not bring it back
I don't understand why
sometimes that happens sometimes
creators just make decisions that
absolutely blow me away and I especially
when I find out that they
are happy that they did do what they
intended or that they didn't think
something was gonna go down the way it
went down I mean to step outside Doctor
Who for a minute I'm still I'm still
bowled over by the fact that the
creators of one division
thought that casting Evan Peters
as a fake version of Wanda's brother
Evan Peters again reminder played kind
of the same character played quicksilver
in the fox X-Men movies before Disney
acquired Fox and the version of Wanda's
brother in the MCU was a completely
different actor and the character's been
dead for a bit
it it blew my mind finding out after the
show was finished that the creators
genuinely thought that putting Evan
Peters in that part would be seen as
just a fun Easter egg
and that people weren't going to think
it meant more and read into it and then
be deeply unhappy when it was nothing
like fans can have excessive
expectations and sometimes it's very
unfair when fandoms get mad at creators
not for something they did but something
that the audience or the fans assumed
they were going to do but then didn't
but the creators themselves basically
never promised that is nonsense and it
does happen I'm not immune from it I've
probably done it
but at the same time how are you so
unplugged so unaware of what the fandom
for your property is like
that you thought people would go oh
that's cute that's a fun Easter egg it
doesn't mean anything
how
and that's
that's kind of a similar general feeling
that I have to chimno like okay if this
was what you wanted to do
how was it that you ever thought that
this was going to go down well though
and again the amount of fan pleasing you
should or shouldn't do that's a very
debatable thing because you know there's
arguments of how much Freedom should a
Creator have to create their own thing
versus what kind of ownership does the
fandom have over a thing and it gets
complicated by something as old as
Doctor Who when you know some fans have
you know could very well have been
watching the show for longer than gibnol
has
um he's been a fan since youth so
probably not as many but like
theoretically this isn't just his
property to do whatever he wants with
and so that complicates things like
there's there's a lot of nuance and
discussion to be had about that
so regardless of exactly where you feel
on how much Freedom a Creator should be
given on a long-running property like
this that's your own determination to
make
but no matter what
I always assumed if he's doing this it
has to be
for
something
but it wasn't
this is so weird
it's just weird
this has been very rambly and it's been
much more about chiminal's mindset I
guess more than anything else because
that's that's just where I'm confused
it's so strange to me
and yet here we are
but
again I want to emphasize
this has not been all bad there are
individual episodes that I've loved and
there are performances that I really
like there are even some of the new
elements brought in like Joe Martin's
fugitive doctor I would very much like
more of please
but when I try and parse just what he
was doing
I I can't even when it's basically laid
out in front of me
I don't get it
and I feel that more than anything kind
of sums up my feeling on chimnal zero as
a showrunner
I don't get it
and that doesn't even necessarily make a
thing bad but at the very least I have
to cop to the fact that
whoever this was for or however this is
going to connect as a whole piece of
work for people it's it's for someone
who isn't me and that's okay
but usually
usually I can understand what was being
tried for and who it was for and this
time it's
it's really hard
but again
if you liked it
great
I wish I did
and there are again individual Parts I
like I like I liked how it ended I liked
power of the doctor I'm kind of excited
to watch that again it was a Thrill Ride
it was wonderful it was nostalgic it was
just it just gave me good feelings all
over and I just wish it was a Capper to
a run of series that I understood
better or at all
I suppose maybe as time goes on I'll
ultimately decide I was trying to read
more into all of this than there ever
was going to be with chimnal and maybe
that's on me because I was used to well
I was used to Moffett for so long and
maybe that just put me in the wrong
headspace to be able to digest what
chibnol was trying to do like maybe with
more distance I'll look back on this and
go
okay like I needed to be in a completely
different headspace and come at this
from a completely different angle to
have a better chance of getting it maybe
not
but this is where I am right now
the end of chippinal zero what'd you
think about that what'd you think about
any of the stuff I've said
in many ways this is old news because
I'm citing you know a
six month old article but like I've got
new context for what he said now I
didn't really talk about this thing at
the time but now I've got full context
for it now that his error's done so this
felt like the time to actually try and
dive into it
but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it I already plugged the
patreon there's a link down in the
description for that as well like share
subscribe are also huge helps but even
if you can't help me out with any of
that I want you to remember that you are
beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
fulla Tarak the theme that goes joint in
the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nabulax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperl
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan
Larose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out thanks so much you
are a pain in my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]